After learning about Plant tissues, let us
take a look at the various types of animal
tissues in details.
In case of animals, where the body is expected
to perform uncountable functions simultaneously,
it is obvious that, the number of tissues
will also be innumerable right?
So how do we study all these?
Well, we don’t need to worry!
For simplicity, we would prefer dividing all
the animal tissues into four major categories,
depending upon their functions.
Firstly, we have the one for PROTECTION, then
another for CONNECTION, followed by MOVEMENT
AND LOCOMOTION, and lastly, for TRANSMISSION
OF SIGNALS for quick and efficient work.
Based on this, we get the
four major types of tissues as
Epithelial, Connective, Muscular and Nervous!
So in this video, let’s begin with the first
type that is epithelial tissue.
As the name says, Epi is Above; thus epithelial
tissue is the one which lies ABOVE the entire
body, forming a protective covering.
Along with covering the body, it also forms
a barrier between the various organs separating
them.
Now the structure of the epithelial tissue
is quite evident from its function.
Yes!
Since it has to form a protective layer, it
cannot afford to have spaces between the cells.
Hence, we find the epithelial tissue to have
tightly packed cells, forming continuous sheets.
The tissue lacks intercellular spaces and
has extremely small amount of cementing material.
So every single substance that passes in or
out of the cells needs to cross the epithelial
layer at least once.
Accordingly, the permeability of cells will
differ in various epithelia depending upon
the exchange of materials.
Now when we talk about all the epithelial
cells in general, we need to first understand
a common characteristic between them.
May it be any different type of Epithelia,
all of them will always have the cells resting
on a thin, fibrous, supportive membrane like structure.
This is called the BASEMENT Membrane.
The basement membrane, apart from supporting,
helps to hold the cells together in a single,
straight line, to form a uniform and consistent layer.
Okay, so getting back to the types of Epithelia…
In order to study them, let’s take a simple
example.
Imagine this to be a Basement Membrane.
Now, depending upon the functions,
let’s classify them:
So let’s say the first function is filtration.
What kind of structure should be
present according to you?
Yes!
It needs to be a very flat surface.
So this type of epithelium is referred to
as Simple Squamous epithelium.
Now let’s take up the next function that
is ABSORPTION AND SECRETION.
For this, obviously we would need a larger
surface area right?
Which is why we have these tall pillar like
cells on the basement membrane, making up
the Columnar epithelium.
Now at times, we need the STRENGTH or support
along with larger surface area.
In this case, we slightly change the structure
to cube like cells, and form the Cuboidal
epithelium.
Lastly, we have certain organs
that need SPECIALISED secretions.
So in such cases, we need to modify a few
cells that would perform secretion of specific
chemicals like hormones or enzymes.
These are called the gland cells, and the
epithelium consisting of such type of cells
is called the Glandular Epithelium.
Well, this was about the epithelial tissue in short.
Now let’s meet up in the next video, where
we will discuss these four types of Epithelia.